what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with Justice incarnate and
single-handedly DC is going to retcon
their entire Multiverse and everything
so this is going to be a pretty
important video that we're doing here
but the thing about this is we basically
pick up immediately after the events of
the last video right where we had like
the bat woman who laughs and remember
she's an agent of the great Darkness so
she was here to basically snatch up the
crack in the Multiverse that if the
crack of the Multiverse is obtained by
the great darkness which is basically
absolute evil that it would be able to
enter into the positive Multiverse and
basically destroy everything in
existence or at least turn it all back
into nothingness again now of course the
the whole thing with Batwoman who laughs
it's more of a cameo than anything else
because once the crack in the Multiverse
escapes her clutches she really just
kind of Retreats right she basically
just takes off that's really all we get
from her we don't really get a whole lot
going on with her character so it's
really just a teaser to see whether or
not there was any interest in the
Batwoman who lives from the DC fan base
and that was effectively it uh the
following this one of the things that we
had talked about is that you had
president Superman and you had Dr
Multiverse who had been lost in a
reality that you also had Captain carrot
who had been lost in his own reality
because of everything that goes on with
his story we're gonna Focus almost
exclusively on President Superman and Dr
Multiverse and so what ends up going on
is they basically arrive at Earth 33.
now those individuals out there who are
eagle-eyed comic book readers you know
that Earth 33 is basically the world of
Superboy Prime it's the real world like
the world that we live in in DC Comics
the problem with this is that Superboy
Prime doesn't show up once and a lot of
that's probably because his story is
done right DC is basically done creating
content with him that may change at some
future point in time but for right now
you don't really see him at all instead
it's basically president Superman and Dr
Multiverse trying to find a way out of
this universe but because it's the real
world their powers are basically
nullified and that's one of the things
to keep in mind is that Superboy Prime
is the only superhero that ever came
from Earth 33 there's nobody else
besides him and so whether it being kind
of the the real world they can't fly
they can't do any of the stuff they
normally do and people honestly think
they're just dressed in Cosplay but they
come to the realization that the only
way for them to escape the only way for
them to get out and really even be able
to communicate with the other members of
the Justice incarnate team is to
actually create superheroes and the
reason why and this is one of those
Grant Morrison uh you know meta
commentary things that's being used by
Joshua Williamson here the reason why is
because in the real world we create
Comics so if you imagine that there is a
universe out there where all of this is
taking place whatever it is that you
write will become true right that'll
become the reality of their story and so
the intention here is to basically craft
a story in a way that allows them to
return and what ends up going on is that
the days sort of pass it's literally day
one the new Jump to day seven you jump
to day 23 right you get to like day 65
and so on and so forth but it's just one
of these things where they're stuck here
for a pretty lengthy period of time
months on end so what ends up going on
here is President Superman ends up
getting a hold of a guy named Ulrich
Saxman who is an actual editor at DC
Comics and the idea here is that Ulrich
Saxman can actually help them craft a
comic in order to have that comic
printed and for that comic to become
reality the funny thing about this is
that as they tell him their story he
simply goes back to his office and he
starts working on notes and so when they
end up meeting up with him the notes
basically indicate that Darkseid has to
win right the dark side is going to win
and it's one of those funny things
because as they have this conversation
they're just kind of like no that's not
going to happen but the funny thing is
Ulrich sachsman kind of chimes in and
says look I totally get your all story I
get everything that's going on and we do
have to get you back to you to you know
your reality that's true we have to get
you back to your normalcy but we also
have to sell comics and whenever
Darkseid wins we sell Comics so at the
end of the day for us here at DC Comics
making money is the name of the game
everything else is secondary and that's
kind of the funny thing because in the
middle of this conversation you
basically end up having Avery who of
course again is the version of The Flash
they're using kind of another flash who
existed in the main DC Universe that
flash actually managed to get a hold of
Thomas Wayne Batman and in turn now
they're all basically going forward and
uh literally reaching out to president
Superman and Dr Multiverse and it's one
of those cool things because what Avery
does is when she's told by Dr Multiverse
like we can't use our powers here her
response is actually you can you just
don't believe that you can because in
the real world whatever you believe it's
it's a reality right your fears your
concerns those become tangible things
and so if the fear when you first
arrived here was we can't use our powers
that becomes your reality so the truth
is you can use them it's just nobody
ever really uses powers on Earth Prime
and Earth 33 so as a result of that you
can't use yours or at least you believe
you can't but the truth about it is they
basically say like we found the crack in
the Multiverse you have to come with us
and that's when Ulrich Saxman Reveals
His true identity which is that he's
actually dark side which is amazing
because Darkseid was stuck here in this
reality posing as a regular human which
really begs the question who at DC
Comics is actually dark side in Disguise
I don't know if that's true I don't know
anything about this guy I didn't even
know he was an editor until I read this
story and I don't even know if he is
actually an editor at DC Comics it just
seems like he is so I just went ahead
and rolled with him but the thing about
this is they basically end up
transitioning with Darkseid to the Earth
that Captain carrots on and this is the
Earth where the actual crack and the
Multiverse is out now remember the crack
in the Multiverse is a tangible thing if
you possess it you can enter in and out
of any Multiverse that you want to and
that's a New Concept because DC is
bringing in this idea that there are now
multiple multiverses in DC Comics as
opposed to one Multiverse with multiple
universes in it and so this is actually
a pretty cool moment because what ends
up happening is Dr Multiverse actually
ends up snatching up the crack in the
Multiverse and at that point Dark Side
satisfied and the reason why is because
she's basically fulfilling this role
where she can contain the crack in the
Multiverse but she can't hold it forever
and that's the cool thing is because
what she ends up basically revealing
here is essentially this giant retcon of
the Multiverse everything we thought we
knew is not actually correct and this is
one of the most significant moments in
DC Comics right it's this really really
cool thing because what she basically
reveals is that dark side does have to
win by possessing the crack in the
Multiverse she now has full knowledge of
the entire multiverses pass everything
going on with the Multiverse and she
knows how things have to transpire and
what she says is in really kind of
giving us the story which again is a
giant retcon she basically says that
like in the beginning there was
basically just darkness right there was
no life or anything like that but the
presence or God effectively created the
Multiverse as it existed and what it did
is it brought light to the dark and it
basically forced the great Darkness to
essentially recede right to basically
Retreat now one of the things that I
want to specify here is that we have to
act as though everything with perpetua
doesn't exist that it never happened and
was never written by DC Comics because
you're never gonna see her referenced
once over the course of this new retcon
that DC is doing so they're literally
undoing it all and they're kind of
reworking the the whole Multiverse or
the history of the Multiverse and
everything else but the thing about this
is that we're told what the original
crisis on infinite Earth's event right
that story had its own plot story right
it had its own plot line the idea behind
it is that the anti-monitor basically
wanted to destroy the positive matter
Multiverse essentially the Multiverse as
it existed by basically spreading
antimatter everywhere right like just
bringing it into it all what the
anti-monitor didn't know is that it was
being used by the great Darkness now
ultimately a truce was brokered between
the great darkness and basically God or
the light if you want to call that the
source and what it meant is that they
would basically stay hands off that with
the destruction of the Multiverse and
the creation of what we call New Earth
in DC Comics basically everything after
the events of crisis on infinite Earth
until Infinite Crisis that it broker to
truce that the great Darkness would
basically stay away that it would sleep
it would basically go into hibernation
and that the the light or the source or
God whatever you want to call it would
be the one that would basically have its
time to Reign and the result of this is
that the great Darkness seemed to do
exactly that except it didn't the
influence of the great Darkness was
consistently felt that when it came to
these various beings who popped up for
example the events of Infinite Crisis
the idea that the Multiverse had
basically been recreated that what it
did is it disrupted the truth between
the great darkness and God and the
result of that is the great Darkness
began to make its move again that it
started impacting everybody like we're
literally told ultimately these
Relentless attacks culminated in another
crisis that forced the lone Multiverse
to evolve into what we now know as the
new Multiverse that was Infinite Crisis
which broke the truce between the great
darkness and the light that monitors
were dispatched By the Light to contain
and limit the new Multiverse to an Ori
of 52 worlds in the hopes of slowing the
Great darkness's Awakening so quite
literally the great Darkness went to
sleep after the events of Christ on
infinite Earth but with something like
the Multiverse being reborn that's
enough to wake it up and where normally
this would lead to to the formation of
an infinite number of universes across
the Multiverse what Joshua Williamson is
establishing here is that it was only
ever 52 worlds that was it it was
literally contained to 52 worlds in the
Multiverse because if there were any
more than 52 if it were to continue
growing the great Darkness would wake up
and the war between the light and the
dark would be on yet again the other
part of this is that Darkseid returned
as a result of the events of Infinite
Crisis that he was one of the few who
was aware of the existence of the great
darkness and the dark side was
instrumental in stopping the
anti-monitor purging the first crisis
that the God of all evil Darkseid
understood a truth about the great
darkness that few ever would that it
does not care for good or evil nor life
or death that the great Darkness only
wants nothing to be everything once more
and that dark side manipulated prophecy
and Destiny to trigger a final crisis so
what Joshua Williamson is saying here is
that in reality the event it's a final
crisis were triggered by Darkseid in
order to find a way to end the the great
Darkness right or at least capture the
great darkness that the great Darkness
has been behind everything right and
literally we're told here all of this
was designed to draw out the great
Darkness so the god of evil could truly
control everything there was only one
thing Darkseid did not count on that his
scheme succeeded but at the cost of his
own life when Batman basically killed
him at the end of final crisis and that
as the Multiverse was at its weakest in
a moment of the Lonely silence right
before a desperate Hail Mary to save it
with a wish on a miracle machine the
great Darkness revealed itself to
Superman in the form of mandrak so for
those of you guys who aren't really
familiar with that mandrak was kind of
like the first monitor during the events
of final crisis mandrak was the most
powerful of all the monitors and in fact
mandrak ended up going toe-to-toe with
Superman and an entire Army of Superman
at the same time the guy was
ridiculously powerful but the reason why
all of this matters is because over the
years in DC Comics we got crisis on
infinite Earth which destroyed the
Multiverse we got Infinite Crisis which
brought it back albeit a different
version of the Multiverse and then final
crisis which made the superheroes aware
of the multiverse's existence but all of
these seem to be just disconnected right
they all have their own individual
stories and there was no unifying theme
among all these crisis events outside of
the fact that they would either reboot
the entirety of the DC landscape or they
would rework the landscape or something
along those lines the truth about what
Joshua Williamson is doing here is he's
saying that every single crisis event
was influenced in some capacity by the
great darkness which wasn't necessarily
awake it was simply just its Essence
permeating throughout everything so it's
like releasing a drop of ink in a glass
of water it's gonna impact everything
else right it's literally going to
change the color of that water and so
the results of this is that with
everything that had gone on following
the events of Infinite Crisis and final
crisis the great Darkness basically woke
up and it came to the realization that
it does have one absolute enemy across
the entire 30 of the Multiverse absent
basically God which was superheroes that
is always superheroes that are stopping
the great Darkness from coming into
existence now one of the more
controversial statements is going to be
made here and I don't know how people
are going to respond to this is that
what the great Darkness did is that in
order to basically demoralize and even
to a degree reduce the power of
superheroes is that during the
flashpoint event that in DC Comics we
got the introduction of Dr Manhattan
from the Watchman universe and what Dr
Manhattan did is he basically modified
history so that like 10 years were
missing from the entire history of
superheroes there was just this giant
Gap and it was all due to the
mechanations of Dr Manhattan that what
we're being told here by Joshua
Williamson is that that was done by the
great Darkness the great Darkness
manipulated Dr Manhattan and basically
screwed everything up so he was the one
behind it all right the great Darkness
has been behind everything every step of
the way ever since the first crisis on
infinite Earth's event and the results
of this is that all these different
scenarios that it unfolded all these
things that taken place even during the
New 52 when Darkseid had basically been
woken up and then gone on a campaign
everything the Darkseid had done when DC
rebooted in the new 52 running all the
way up until now has been trying to find
a way to seize control of the great
Darkness so he can control everything in
existence and the reality of this even
going into like dark Knight's metal
right the Batman who last and all that
stuff Barbados who was an agent of the
great Darkness yet again an instance
where the great Darkness was trying to
destroy the Multiverse trying to seize
control when Darkseid was imprisoned
basically on Earth Omega this kind of
Lone universe that existed out there
that was just a heinously dark place
where he ultimately killed his captors
and then escaped and was back on the
hunt to try to find a way to stop the
great Darkness it's all been him but
it's all been dark side and that's where
Dr Multiverse tells us this whole story
and says okay that's why Darkseid has to
win because the reality here is that if
Darkseid gets the crack in the
Multiverse and then dark side uses the
crack in the Multiverse to seize control
of the great Darkness then ultimately we
May kind of stand a chance potentially
against Darkseid or at least we could
defeat him but if the great Darkness
gets the crack in the Multiverse and the
great Darkness enters our positive
Multiverse there's no reasoning with it
there's no talking it down there's no
defeating it there's nothing we can do
here we will all perish we will all die
and that'll be the end of it so we
literally have to Ally ourselves with
one evil that we could potentially
defeat to stop a greater evil that we
have no chance of defeating and that's
ultimately exactly how things seem to
play out that one of the things that
goes on here is you literally have an
attempt by the different members of the
of Justice incarnate to basically face
off against the forces of Darkseid and
at least to try to stop Darkseid himself
albeit literally sealing their Destiny
it's the worst thing they could do here
but in the end they're like we Ally
ourselves with good and yada yada the
reality here is that in order to win
they are going to have to join with
Darkseid there's no way to stop the
coming of the great Darkness unless they
do that now there is also an attempt by
Thomas Wayne Batman remember that's the
Batman from the flashpoint Universe from
alternate reality that Thomas Wayne
tries to kill Dr Multiverse and that's
when it's basically revealed to us and
really even revealed by Darkseid that
the great Darkness has seized control of
Thomas Wayne Batman now it has all the
information that Thomas Wayne Batman had
and so ultimately Darkseid says there's
no way to basically get around this
there's no way to undo the influence of
the great Darkness on Thomas Wayne he
has to die and using his Omega beams he
incinerates Thomas Wayne on the spot
literally kills him and just that's it
there's no more Thomas Wayne anymore
which seems to be Joshua Williamson's
way of basically getting rid of him
following that he ends up just taking
out each member of the of the Justice
incarnate seizes control of Dr
Multiverse and steals the crack of the
Multiverse directly away from her and
now in darkseid's possession the other
part of this is that back on Earth 7 we
have the emergence of the empty hand now
if we were to apply this to like Marvel
terms if the great Darkness were
Galactus the empty hand is the Silver
Surfer he's an agent of the great
Darkness now he is astronomically
powerful one thing that I want to
specify here when it comes to the
hierarchy of power in DC Comics this
guy's up there this guy is way up there
like the empty hand is ridiculously op
there's virtually nothing this guy can't
do compared to pretty much anything that
any of the superheroes can do right this
guy could demolish Superman without even
thinking about it right like like
literally that's that's one of the
things to know Superman's powerful right
Superman's incredibly powerful this guy
would demolish him and be home in time
for cornflakes that's just one thing to
understand this guy's that op but the
funny thing about this is this is also
True Form dark side it's every version
of dark side merged into one this is the
most powerful darkseid's ever been
possessing the crack in the Multiverse
Dark Side literally becomes full of
hubris he makes a Gambit and he stabs
the empty hand with the crack and the
Multiverse in doing this the belief of
Darkseid is it'll destroy the empty hand
and that by doing that it leaves the
landscape open for Darkseid to then
seize control of the great Darkness the
entire opposite happens and in fact the
empty hand just reveals you have been a
great puppet Dark Side you have done
exactly as you were supposed to do and
you never even knew that was the case
that the reality here is dark side
stabbing the empty hand with a crack in
the Multiverse is not going to kill the
empty hand and is not going to allow him
to to conquer and control the great
Darkness instead he literally delivered
the crack to the great Darkness itself
the empty hand is beyond this level of
of of death right it's beyond this level
of power it's too powerful right it's
like stabbing The Incredible Hulk with a
knife nothing's gonna happen right and
if anything all you're going to do is
piss him off and that's exactly what
happens right literally the empty hand
is like my hand is no longer empty and
seizing control of the great crack
literally takes out Darkseid and so one
of the things that you get is the empty
hand basically forming a portal right
like like literally opening a portal to
get to the Great darkness and then
actually taunts dark side and is like if
you dare an invitation beckons right
empty is my hand do you live up to the
challenge and dark side always one that
is just exceedingly prideful ends up
daring and enters into the portal and is
immediately confronted by the great
Darkness now here's a funny thing about
this darkseid's ridiculously powerful
Darkseid is a ridiculously op force of
energy this guy is on a whole nother
level when he gets in there he starts
screaming at the great Darkness right
face me and the ultimately the great
darkness is just like control is an
illusion right your mind is already mine
behold my right hand the one that is
empty the one that takes but consider
the left hand the one that closed the
unknown fist that destroys and when
darkseides just like I am no puppet I am
nobody to be manipulated the great
darkness is just like what you want is
irrelevant it doesn't matter the fist
cannot say to the body I have no need of
you and so what this basically means is
when Darkseid entered into the realm of
the great Darkness he was immediately
overtaken he never stood a chance he
never had the chance to overtake the
great Darkness there was there was no
possibility there I mean it's just
something to grasp here right I mean
it's just it's it's a ridiculous concept
whether there is a force of energy out
there that is so astronomically powerful
that the entire possibility of Darkseid
even potentially considering the option
of even having a chance was nullified
the instant that he meant it right there
was nothing he ever could have done it's
just it's so insane and so ultimately
what ends up happening is you basically
have the Justice incarnate that come to
the realization okay dark side is out of
the picture and now he's an agent of the
great Darkness like there's nothing we
can do there right and so their whole
thing is we came here to basically save
Barry Allen we have to go find beer we
have to enter into whatever reality he's
in in order to locate him and ultimately
they do right they pass through the
portal now one of the things to know
here is that where the dark side
situation the portal led him to the
great darkness that doesn't necessarily
seem to be the case right the portal
seems to only ever lead to one of two
places the first is the other world
Universe which we know nothing about the
only thing we know about it is what
you're about to see here in a second the
other location is the realm of the great
Darkness now which one you end up going
to I don't know if it's based on your
alignment with a light or the dark but
regard list when they end up emerging in
this other world place that they
basically get there and of course
they're taken by Wallace West the new 52
version of Wally West they're brought to
basically Barry Allen and they
immediately try to confront him right
because Barry doesn't know who they are
he's never seen them and never heard of
them he's like I have no idea what's
going on now obviously this is the
result of the fact that this place is
basically screwed up Barry's mind
because Barry does know who these people
are or at least some of them I don't
think he knows who Dr Multiverse is but
he does know who president Superman is
and he absolutely knows who Captain
Karen is Captain carrot Captain carrots
a super bunny but he should know exactly
who Captain carrot is but the thing
about this is that when they try to get
Barry Allen away from this place he
immediately turns against them literally
knocks him off guard and then races back
into the house and that's it and that's
when Pariah makes his appearance now we
haven't talked a whole lot about his
character we did at the beginning or at
least towards the end of the uh Justice
League story that we did before this for
those of you guys who aren't familiar
with Pariah he's ridiculously op and in
fact we'll find out how powerful he is
here in a second because as soon as he
emerges Dr multi person's like we have
to go like if we stay here this is going
to be the end of it she's so terrified
of this guy she literally snatches up
the Justice incarnate and flees right
just takes off literally teleports them
out of there and when the whole question
is okay why did we do this because
literally as they as they teleport out
they just jump they don't even have a
destination she has no idea where she's
taking them this literally anywhere is
better than here with this guy now of
course you do also have the remainder of
the Justice incarnate that are basically
trying to escape the great darkness
which is now influencing and spreading
into the positive Multiverse so it's
literally entering in right I mean
there's nothing that can be done now
like it's entering into the positive
Multiverse The the Reserve members of
the Justice incarnate basically rescue
the main team and when President Calvin
or president Superman is like why did
you take us away from there we were
supposed to save Barry Allen she's like
no you don't understand that guy is more
powerful than the empty hand and dark
side combined that guy's on a whole new
level of power it's like he's the voice
of the great Darkness but whatever it is
that's going on with that guy he's on a
whole different level we never even
remotely stood a chance and if he had
touched us we would have ended up just
like Barry Allen he would have been
stuck there there would have been nobody
to save the day and so ultimately with
the great Darkness spreading throughout
the Multiverse president Superman says
okay fine there's only one place for us
to go we have to go find the Justice
League but what it does is it switches
over to the great darkness which
literally hasn't snared some of the most
powerful beings in existence under its
control we're talking about like necron
who is quite literally uh the the leader
of the Black Lanterns represents death
in a lot of different ways um that you
have the empty hand who's there of
course you also have a Calypso who's
basically the wrath of God and then
you've got Darkseid who's also ensnared
as well so these are ridiculously
powerful forces that are all being
controlled by the great Darkness just to
give you guys an understanding any one
of these guys is more than enough to
take on a Justice League more than
enough to be able to handle the Justice
League and even the Justice League would
probably struggle against one of these
guys right like if they weren't just
outright quite defeated now you're
talking about an army of them and that
Army is only going to get larger so with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end thank you all for
watching and I will catch you all later
peace